voilà ces prix des biens sous l'été
début jusqu'à la fin j'ai maintenant
jean louis aubert va nous faire un
cadeau formidable parce que chaque fois
que j'arrête une émission jeu mais voilà
c'est fini on a dû se tenir prêtes et là
ce soir pour la première fois jean-louis
même le chanteur après
[Applaudissements]
oui
c'est un beau cadeau
voilà
c'est fini on attend ressasser les mêmes
théories on a tellement tirer chacun de
notre côté
que voilà
c'est fini trouve un autre rocher
petites huîtres pearl et ne laisse pas
trop coulé de temps sous ton petit nez
et thierry
car ce fini
c'est fini
[Musique]
voilà
c'est fini on va passer en voir comme
sur le quai d'une gare je dis seulement
bonjour et fais gaffe à l'amo
voilà
ces fumées
aujourd'hui on demain c'est le moment où
tu es mais peut-être après deux matches
et nous
retrouvera
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
car cette année
c'est une
ta fille par te dire qu'on éviterait le
pire
à
coupez plutôt que déchirait
finis par te dire que peut-être on va
grandir
[Musique]
et que même si c'est non
et que même si ces cons
et de nous savons
de toute façon
voilà
ce fut ni ne soit jamais à mr reste
toujours sincère
tu as eu ce que tu as voulu
et t'as pas voulu ce que tu as eue
voilà
certes
la soul nous chacun
notre côté
car c'est fini
allez à l'année prochaine
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux